みんなバスケ上手いなぁ気づきましたか
そうなんです
バスケットボールやってたユーチューバー
さん結構いるんですけども上手い人
多いんですよ
こんにちははじめ社長です何から話そうか
な
もうでも動画なタイトル見たらわかると
思うんですけども僕
[音楽]
食っちまいましたユーチューバーで
最強のバスケっチェーンぬ
まずはこちらをご覧くださいどうぞ
はいた場合はも損でしょねしまーすせない
でしょう頑張ってみましょうお茶を見でた
大祭司まあ今日はですねずっとやりたかっ
た企画があるんでそれの準備がようやくだ
と思ったということで
やりたいんですけども
はいっ
ni所詮
この後思っちゃいます
ああああああben
ああああああああ
かっこいい
すらなかったら台パンでました
これやっぱりいける地力で9ああ
voodoo
[拍手]
理由した
うわーっ
pou
dou
[音楽]
ano
デーちゃまー402
[音楽]
ana
rel
きゅん
きゅんっ
はいいかがだったでしょうか
どうですかな語るメンバーこれすごくない
ですか dream team dream
team まずは言いだしっぺ私和美社長
そして水玉でポンドから館た簡単もずっと
一緒にバスケやってますねそしてオネエ
クレイの友やばすけって言ったらこの人を
外せないですよもうそしてさはやゲーム
からサバとやん筋肉声です暴力とで com
.からいうた言うな com .と結構
バスケーションにせてこの2人がちょっと
ず版だけていたというか甘かったので
こちらも注意咥えさせて今のところ7人で
you to bar でチームを作らせ
ていただきましたお金はいろんなもちろん
パフューマーユーチューバーさ本当にも
いっぱいいますよいますひょっとした
わかんない秘境あのまだ増えるかもしれ
ませんですと忙しい
ユーチューバー忙しいんですよ忙しくて
なかなかもいろんな一番まとめチェリー
しようと思ったんですけどもいろいろ都合
が合ったり合わなかったりで1丁今9暫定
をこのメンバーで確定でございますでなぜ
こんなチーム作ったかと言いますとズバリ
発表させていただきます一紗ちゃんと川崎
ブレイブサンダース presents
ドリームゲーム200210にくい
eighter 採用チームがプロバスケ
チームに挑んでみたーーー
[音楽]
開催確定します決定ですかね皆さんこれ
いう観客自社やります plot 俺たち
が日時です2022年今年の夏もう夏休み
ですね8月の30日今のところ決まってる
のが会場が17:00から19時ですね
もう1回いいまでは8月の30日の退場が
17:00そして開演が19時からになっ
ております今日のまた変わるかもしれない
ですけどもそれぞれ皆さん8月30日上げ
ておいてくださいこんなことないよいう
観客で聞いたことないでしょはじめさぞの
水たまりポッド com .とサワーやん
げーむずともや一緒にバッグしするって
ドリームゲームですよまじでで it がー
クロカワ下げブレイブサンダース俺の中で
はもう夏の一番のビッグイベントだと思っ
てます凄いですよもうショットしたら最初
で財布がを剃れないぐらい夢のような
チームなのでちょっと皆さん是非初月さん
と実は見に行ってくださいいろんな
クリエイターさんが協力して強くなって
プロとったんですよ勝てるわけない
でしょう文分やる前から5ダメて当てます
フェアじゃだめじゃんルール編ことをし
てるからまぁちょっとでも本当は結局俺
たちはユーチューバーと言うけどが
クレーターなんでガツガツっていうわけで
はないような教師てます正直どうだこれも
ちょっとよく分かってないけどとりあえず
ねあの面白いものができればいいかなって
思ってますでなんですねイベントがオン
ライン無料配信に赤いを配しても予定して
おりますので詳細はまた後日発表させて
いただきます会場川崎市の等々力アリーナ
神奈川県ですね彼は席のとどろきアリーナ
で解体いただきますチケット販売なんです
けども2022年の6月の11日から6月
の30日までつ局の販売ありますのでぜひ
本当に行ったほうがいいと思うないよ
こんな機会実態気になると思う結構
ユーチューバーってたバックので結構あげ
てるじゃないですかあれ
ギターのところだけカットする可能性ある
と思うんですよ僕もたまにカットしてます
実際プロ目の前にしてどこまでできるかと
かすごい気になると思うしもちろんプロに
まっとうにやって勝てると思ってないので
それぞれの施策はの準備しようかなとは
思ってるもちろん川崎ブレイブサンダース
さんも試合できるほどものすごいけど
やっぱり何より一色年ばすぎるやろもどっ
富沢に戻さ早い県別巴基そうでしょでも年
かねもうちょっとメンバーを増やしたいな
とは思ってるんですけどもちょっとどう
なるが4月まだ分からないですけどこの
メンバーと列確定できますのでみなさん
ぜひドリームゲーム2020に足を運んで
バスティアしたよ見に行ってみてください
もうこれが俺の夏が一番ビッグイベントだ
ねそうじきもっと練習とかしたいんです
けどもどうなんだろうか youtube
でいそうは c から時間合わせて練習
できるのかなと思うちょっとまずはみんな
と相談してちょっと練習とかできたらいい
なと思う
やるからには一生懸命頑張りたいと思い
ますのでぜひ皆さんユーチューバー再起を
ズーム
では8月30日とどろきアリーナでお待ち
しておりますじゃあ
el
[音楽]